I have one more question that might be a
virgin in approps but I have what advice
would you give to let's say a 13 year
old girl who is curious about sex and
whatnot who types in porn on the youtube
search engine like what do you if you
had a daughter and she is you can tell
that she's wanting to look for it online
and it's a huge that she types and porn
on YouTube mm-hmm what do you tell her I
mean like if it were me I would like if
it were my kid you know I would it's
more than like what I would tell them
like I cuz I I definitely want to like
spread the vibe that like it's perfectly
natural to feel sexual and to be curious
about sex and to want to see porn like I
think that's very very normal and like I
didn't grow up thinking that was normal
so I felt super ashamed about it I think
it's more though like more than like
what we say about that I think it's more
I would make sure that that 13 year old
girl had sexual education aside from
porn you know I mean like I would want
to inform her about safe sex consent
STDs and and just you know how natural
and normal it is for all of us to be
sexual human beings yeah that's what
I've been this this girl lives in a very
like deeply Catholic country where
there's no sex ed so the only sex that
they get is here's a penis here's a
vagina
that's really yeah
you know like imagine like especially
like imagine a boy who's raised like
that sees a gangbang corn and thinks
like oh my god this is like what I'm
supposed to be doing to women like no
but if that boy were taught that you
know some people enjoy stuff like this
some people don't and you can decide for
yourself if you do when you're older
like all that stuff is like you know I
think I think if I was a teenager I was
in a gangbang I don't think I would say
no wait isn't that how you lost your
virginity you were 9th in line yeah but
that was yeah yeah yeah I wasn't oh yeah
I was nothing like yeah yeah yeah out of
how many
9 9 he was not the caboose every time
hold on wait who were you a giant he
just [ __ ] the [ __ ] puddle of come
how old were you can you say I really
like to say things like 7 16 or 16 17
and were you banging gangbanging
no it was no it was like you had a
waiting line like you're like it was
Disneyland or something who decides who
goes first it was bigger to smaller
jocks no but in the gangbang with the
jocks that's pretty cool no I was on the
wrestling team was like the wrestling
team
hey Chad went up first and then the
Jose's in the Pedro's and then the you
know me damn that's crazy
yeah I've been in the gangbang in real
life who orchestrates that it wasn't
something that it wasn't like you know a
production like a meet-up calm there
wasn't like the pre-production meeting
or like I I would have loved to get
gangbanged no you're at a party right
it's like it's 1:00 in the morning
you're in high school there's a party
and a bunch of guys get in line you go
hey can I write and then they they go
you're at the end so I just waited in
line at the end who would say hey can i
Bobby do you a polite consenting yeah
because I don't wanna write like I went
to people [ __ ] and think can i no no
I think the girl was like yeah you all
guys can't I like I didn't I think I
asked the girl and can I get you know I
mean it she's like yeah because I don't
the worst would be is to get in the line
be the last guy and they come up to the
girl and
[Music]
this guy and then I just be like I would
walk away real sad I think yeah yeah
anyway also we love you so much
and we want to see you more often okay
yes okay and I love you so much we love
you
and you want anything the plug or
anything